that are reaching a milestone today and  they did it in really special fashion  ten-year-old Harley was treated to  really an extravagant day for the  organization's 25th hundred wish and  she's just getting started Harley  suffers from a rare respiratory and  Rheumatology disorder her wish began  today take a look at her arrival  Harley's wish is really unique she's so  much time in clinics and everything like  that that really what she wanted is what  we're calling the time of her life and I  can't think of a better place to have  the time of your life than at Resorts  World  [Applause]  I love it love the enthusiasm for Harley  her wish consists of a visit to enchant  pizza making at Mulberry Street a  makeover a David Blaine show the rooftop  Igloo experience and more both Harley  and her mom just overcome with emotion  and look forward to the rest of that  Bevy of fun activities